Wow first I'm going to ask the members
of my crew who are here to join me wow
this is really incredible thank you so
much for the Academy for this incredible
award this has been an amazing week
thank you for everyone who made it so
amazing and memorable and I'm really
honored to be in a group that has so
much talent so I really enjoy my time
with you guys thank you I wouldn't be
standing here tonight if it wasn't for
so so so so many people first I'm going
to start with my amazingly talented crew
facturing cry guys my composure le boom
bass my co-producer Mickey Lewis another
co-producer Felicia hunters my producer
and you're not on the team but sure most
welcome I want to thank my crew and all
those who are not here with me tonight
no seriously I have there's so many
people who are not here and who made
this film possible I want to thank Mark
photo/robyn siad so many people thank
you everyone and you guys for believing
this project ever since you read the
script I want to thank my our generous
backers on Kickstarter without them we
wouldn't have been able to shoot it was
as simple as that I want to thank my
inspiring teachers at Columbia
University Erich Mendelsohn Nick prefers
remember Ronny thank you for everything
you taught me and thank you for your
precious advices I want to thank my dear
dear dear friends Mary Jo Mario Kathleen
groups the list is long but without
their support I added myself so many
times and whenever I doubted myself they
were like you're gonna make it you're
gonna do it so thank you and finally my
entire family I mean especially my my
dear parents
to whom I dedicate this film without you
nothing was possible and one last thing
I'd like to say especially to the
Academy I mean thank you so much for
having us here and for providing us an
opportunity to get our message out there
and so our story takes place in a
ravaged little Eastern neighborhood and
when our message is one of hope and when
people are hopeless and desperate it
becomes easier to turn to extremism and
in a world that is torn by Wars
fanaticism devastation art is a mighty
tool that helps us fight extremism and
terrorism so thank you to the Academy
for joining our fight and we here take
so many things for granted some like
freedom of speech and expression and in
many parts of the world these are
luxuries that must be fought for every
day so thank you thank you everyone